A DEVASTATING SCANDAL IN THE
WORLD OF SPORT.
AT A FISHING IN CLEVELAND ON
FRIDAY.
A DUO DECLARED WINNERS CAUGHT
CHEATING.
OF COURSE, THIS WAS FISHING.
AFTER CAUGHT, THEY WERE
RELEASED.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>>> AND THAT IS THE PERFECT
SEGUE TO OUR NEXT GUEST THERE.
REFERENCING THE INVESTIGATION
UNDER WAY IN AN APPARENT
CHEATING SCANDAL AT A WALLEYE
FISHING TOURNAMENT ON FRIDAY.
JAKE RUNYAN AND CHASE COMINSKY
SET TO WIN A NEARLY $30,000
PRIZE WHEN DISQUALIFIED AFTER
DISCOVERED THEIR FISH WAS
STUFFED WITH LEAD WEIGHTS AND
FISH FILETS.
HERE'S THE MOMENT.
>> WE GOT WEIGHTS IN THE FISH!
>> THERE WE GO!
>> [ BLEEP ] -- NO!
[ BLEEP ] -- [ BLEEP ].
>> GET OUTTA HERE!
>> [ BLEEP ] -- [ BLEEP ] --
BLN.
>>.
>> YOU "BLACK [ B YOU -- WHERE'
ONE?
>> TENSIONS RAN VERY HIGH AFTER
THAT MOMENT.
JOINING US, STEVE HENDRIX,
COMPETITOR ANGLER PART OF THE
COMPETITION THERE FOR THAT
MOMENT.
STEVE AND HIS TEAMMATE RYAN
ENDED UP WINNING TEAM OF THE
YEAR HONORS AFTER THOSE TWO
ALLEGEDLY CHEATING FISHERMEN
WERE DISQUARTERED.
FIRST OFF, CONGRATULATIONS.
A BIG HONOR, TO BE TEAM OF THE
YEAR, BUT TELL US ABOUT THIS
MOMENT AS YOU WITNESSED THESE
LEAD BALLS BEING PULLED FROM
THESE FISH.
WHAT WAS THAT LIKE?
>> WELL, IT WAS A CRAZY WEEKEND.
WE HAD, THEY CAKE UP AND HAD
THEIR FISH OUT IN THE TANK AND
THEY WERE GETTING READY TO COME
UP AND THEY PICKED UP A FISH
THAT SHOULD HAVE WEIGHED ABOUT
FOUR POUNDS, SET IT ON THE
SCALE, IT SAID EIGHT, PUT THE
REST OF THE FIVE, CAME UP TO 35.
EVERYBODY WAS GOING NUTS YOU CAN
SEE IN THE VIDEO.
VERY OBVIOUS THIS TIME THEY
WEREN'T GOING TO GET AWAY WITH
THAT.
IT'S JUST -- IT'S A SHAME THAT
HAD TO HAPPEN, AND I'M JUST GLAD
THEY GOT CAUGHT AND IT'S BEEN A
LONG TIME COMING.
SO --
>> A LONG TIME COMING, YOU SAID.
YOU'VE SUSPECTED THIS IN
PREVIOUS COMPETITIONS.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE'VE LEARNED
THERE ARE ACTUALLY POLYGRAPHS IN
LARGER COMPETITIONS AND ONE OF
THESE COMPETITORS FAIL ADD
POLYGRAPH IN A PREVIOUS ONE
WHICH COST THEM.
YOU SUSPECTED THIS?
YOU AND OTHERS?
>> PEOPLE HAD GOODED?
S AND THOUGHTS ABOUT IT, BUT
LIKE ANYTHING, YOU WANT TO GIVE
PEOPLE BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT,
BUT, YOU KNOW, SOME, WHEN YOU
FAILED ONE AND PASS ONE AND
THERE'S DIFFERENT THINGS AND
THEY BLOW EVERYBODY OUT OF THE
WATER BY FIVE, SIX, SEVEN, EIGHT
POUNDS EVERY TIME AND JUST --
YOU KNOW, SOME SHADY STUFF GOING
ON.
SO -- THEY'VE BEEN INVESTIGATED,
DONE THE POLYGRAPHS.
JASON FISCHER'S DONE A GREAT JOB
TRYING TO DO POLYGRAPHS AND
TESTING, ASKING QUESTIONS AND
DOING EVERYTHING HE CAN DO TO
KEEP IT LEGIT, BUT -- THEY GOT
IT THIS TIME.
SO --
>> YOU KNOW, I WONDER IN THIS
CASE, TALKING ABOUT WEIGHTS OF
ALMOST EIGHT POUNDS.
SEEMS LIKE MAYBE IF THEY'D GONE
FOR LESS THEY WOULD HAVE GOTTEN
AWAY WITH IT AND STILL WON.
WHAT NEEDS TO CHANGE IN PRO
FISHING TO MAKE SURE THIS
DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN?
>> WELL, I THINK THEY'RE GOING
TO BRING IN SOME MAYBE SOME KIND
OF X-RAY.
MAYBE SCANNING, OR MAYBE -- TOP
FIVE BOATS MAYBE OPEN THE FISH
TO SEE WHAT'S IN THE FISH,
AND -- THAT WAY TAKE ALL THE
QUESTION OUT OF IT.
I MEAN, THERE'S -- THIS IS A
RARE, RARE THING.
99.9% OF THE GROUP IS, THERE'S
NONE OF THIS.
THIS ISN'T SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENS ALL THE TIME, AND YOU
KNOW, WE GOT A GREAT GROUP OF
GUYS, A LOT OF BENEFITS AND
DONATION.
WE HAVE GREAT SPONSORS.
IT'S A GREAT GROUP OF GUYS OUT
THERE DOING WHAT THEY LOVE, AND
THIS IS JUST A SHAME WE HAD TO
DEAL WITH THIS, BUT AT THE SAME
TIME IT'S A GOOD THING.
IT WILL BE AN EYE-OPENER FOR
EVERYBODY AND WE GOT THE BAD
ONES OUT OF THERE.
GOING FORWARD, THERE WILL BE,
LIKE I SAY, MAYBE A FEW ITEM AND
KICKING AROUND A BUNCH OF IDEAS
WHAT TO DO TO MAKE IT BETTER.
>> A LOT OF MONEY AT STAKE HERE
BOTH IN EARNINGS AND WHEN IT
COMES TO SPONSORSHIPS FOR SURE,
BUT COUNTY PROSECUTORS IN
CLEVELAND HAVE OPENED AN
INVESTIGATION INTO THIS.
HAVE YOU TALKED TO THEM?
WHAT DO YOU THINK NEEDS TO
HAPPEN HERE?
>> I REALLY HAVEN'T.
WE JUST, YOU KNOW, JASON, THE
TOURNAMENT DIRECTOR, JASON
FISCHER, HE HANDED OVER
EVERYTHING THAT WE HAD.
THEY WERE THERE COLLECTING
EVIDENCE AND GETTING EVERYTHING.
I JUST HOPE THAT, I HOPE THEY
GET THEM FOR EVERYTHING THEY CAN
FOR WHAT THEY'VE DONE TO
EVERYBODY.
THESE GUYS ARE OUT THERE.
GOT A LOT OF MONEY TIED UP IN
TRUCKS AND BOATS AND TRAVEL AND
WORK, AND IT MEANS A LOT TO
THEM.
THAT'S WHAT THEY LOVE DO TO AND
OUT THERE TRYING TO DO A GREAT
JOB AND IT'S UNFORTUNATE A
SELECT FEW CAN COME IN AND RUIN
ALL THAT FOR YOU.
SO I HOPE THEY GET THE MAX.
>> UNBELIEVABLE MOMENT CAUGHT ON
CAMERA THERE.
STEVE, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING WITH US AGAIN, AND ALSO
CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN TO YOU AND
YOUR PARTNER.
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THIS
MORNING.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.